since the launch of titanfall this past
March our number one priority has been
to continue to deliver exciting and new
content to our fans in addition to our
three DLC map packs we've also created a
huge amount of content through our free
updates taking fan feedback to heart
we're constantly working to improve the
game for everyone and to give all seven
million unique users new ways to play
titanfall featured game modes are
something that we were really excited to
bring to our players we've already seen
some great reactions to modes like mark
for death and pilot skirmish which is a
highly competitive 8v8 pilots only mode
and we're eager to see how gamers tackle
some of our other new modes like deadly
ground where the ground is covered in
electrified slope and wall running and
rooftop play are essential to stayin
alive
getting these modes into rotation will
continue to give our players new and
fresh ways to experience titanfall one
of the other great experiences we've
brought to titanfall is frontier defense
join forces with up to three other
players in this cooperative game road to
defend a vital objective for the
recently intense waves of AI combat
we've added new features like deployable
sentry turrets wave dropping it and all
new variations of existing AI foes
like archetype suicide specters and many
more available on all maps players will
have to work together across the entire
frontier of titanfall seasons players
can challenge themselves to beat their
best score and try to earn a three star
rating on each map great job everyone
another one of our goals has been to
allow players to experience titanfall of
their way we've added an ever-evolving
private match system allowing players to
customize their game by tweaking game
rules and settings and offering multiple
options for burn card usage rank GFF
pages for our hardcore fans we
introduced ranked play challenging
players to prove their skill I am
tracking your performance
we've also added Titan insignias to let
players further express their own
personalities and accomplishments
you can complete challenges to obtain
tightened emblems and choose the OS
voice of your Titan to match your style
I remain partly illuminated there's also
the black market by completing
challenges and trading in unwanted burn
cards players can use their in-game
currency to purchase specific burn card
packs unique emblems for their Titans or
even a skip of particularly hard Jen
challenge with all three DLC map packs
now available set across the various
exotic and exciting environments at the
frontier there's more titanfall than
ever for players to sink their teeth
into we've been delighted with all the
positive responses and kind words from
our amazing and dedicated titanfall
communities
we can't wait to share the future of
titanfall with you see you on the
frontier